[Music]
thanks to curiositystream for supporting
this episode go to
curiositystream.com
microcosmos to start streaming thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction tv
shows
[Music]
[Music]
we have spent most of our journey
through the microcosmos seeking out the
organisms that are too small to see with
the human eye the bacteria the ciliates
the tardigrades and part of what makes
them so exciting is that they are so
tiny
every moment we spend with one of these
organisms is a peek into something
exceptional in our experience in the
world
and it is the result of how much work
james our master of microscopes has to
put into hunting down as many microbes
as he can and sometimes that effort
takes a lot of persistence take for
example the creature we are going to
focus on today the bristle worm
this has been one of the white whales
for our channel for some time and as you
watch it you can perhaps understand why
we have been searching so hard for it
it's got the body of a pipe cleaner with
the head of a cartoon dragon
and maybe you also understand that just
because we've been waiting to find one
of these worms that doesn't mean we are
guaranteed anything after all one of the
things you have to accept about the
microcosmos and microbe hunting is that
it is a big world full of tiny creatures
and it can take a while to find some of
them the fact that we are showing you
one of these bristle worms right now
spoils the twist we would usually build
into but surprise we found a bristle
worm the real twist is that this was not
the first bristle worm we found this was
the first bristle worm we found 20
centimeters of segments and bristles
climbing up the side of a tank before
burrowing back beneath the sand
unfortunately that's just about all the
video we got of that bristle worm james
spent so much time trying to find that
bristle worm again that he started to
feel a connection to it so he decided to
give it a name it is named gunther
james spent hours trying to catch it
without hurting the worm but gunther has
hundreds of appendages that can grab
onto sand and james didn't want to
accidentally snap the worm in half with
his tweezers so instead of showing all
the features of gunther that he wanted
to show we are going to show clips of
this bristle worm instead because it
kind of resembles gunther except it's a
lot tinier
gunther is hopefully still somewhere in
that tank living a nice life in the
burrow it dug for itself but it's hard
to know exactly where in the tank
gunther made its home because it would
only show activity in the dark the
moment james tried to turn the lights on
and watch the worm in motion it would
vanish again under the sand and as it
became harder and harder to find james
kept hoping that one day something would
bring another bristle worm to him
and then
one day
james received a package from a coral
farm containing sediments and other
things that might contain some
interesting organisms and we talked
about some of those organisms that james
found in our last episode but in
addition to all of those
james found several species of his long
sought-after bristle
[Music]
worm bristle worms are also known as
poly ketes and they're part of the
segmented worm phylum known as annelids
the name polychaete translates in greek
to many hairs
those stiff hairs are called siti and
for most polychaetes they are attached
to paddle-like appendages called the
parapodia that branch off each segment
of the worm
our giant friend gunther most likely
belongs to the order unicida but its
microscopic look-alike is more unknown
to us but we can imagine that it spends
its life crawling around the sand and
feeding on algae or whatever else it can
take a bite out of you can see this one
moving its mouth in slow motion like a
weird pair of pincers inside clamping
down on something and the movement is
even more dramatic in full speed
this probably looks like a bunch of tiny
individual orange worms tangled together
but it is in fact a worm belonging to
the genus serotolis that can get to
around 12
centimeters in length and along with its
distinctive color the worm is easy to
spot and wet sandy mud because of those
threads you see waving across your
screen
some of these threats are tentacles but
others are actually gills and in the
water those threads seem to float
serenely but this effect is lost on land
in a paper from the beginning of the
20th century titled notes on the ecology
of cirotolous tentaculatus the author
wrote
when withdrawn from the mud ceratolos
presents an exceeding limp and
bedraggled appearance
this worm has a more imposing appearance
but also a funnier name it belongs to
the terra bellid order but it's known as
a spaghetti worm these tropical worms
live in sand building tubes out of
gravel and limestone to live in their
tentacles spill out from the tube
sometimes extending as far as a meter to
gather building materials and food for
the worm
to reproduce spaghetti worms will
release their eggs and sperm into the
water but only at night and sometimes
even without other males or females
around they seem to do this on a lunar
cycle with a limited two-week window for
those gametes to release and find each
other that seems like an extraordinarily
chancy way to reproduce but it seems to
work for this worm
these are the bristle worms we were able
to find from our coral samples and so it
seems like our hunt for this white whale
might be over
except the more we've been reading about
bristle worms the more we wish we could
find even more because these are an
animal whose existence seems designed to
inspire lists of fun facts and bizarre
trivia there are thousands of species of
polyketes and they all seem to have
something remarkable or weird about them
some spend their lives in tubes that
stick up from the sand using their
parapodia to paddle water through the
burrow others have managed to carve out
lives near hydrothermal vents some sound
like they are straight out of a horror
novel growing up to 10 feet long or
dining on the bones of decomposing
animals and some even have eyes on both
ends of their bodies
so knowing that there are all of these
different species out there how could we
ever end our quest for the bristle worm
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
this episode was brought to you by
curiositystream a subscription streaming
service that offers thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction tv shows
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including award-winning exclusives and
originals they cover topics like history
nature science food technology travel
and more and to balance out all of the
creepy crawlies you've been watching
throughout this episode this week we're
going to recommend checking out the
science of cute on curiosity stream not
only will you get to see a bunch of very
cute puppies but you will also learn
about the domestication of dogs and how
their behavior and anatomy has changed
over time to make them just the cutest
little things ever you can stream
curiosity streams library including
their collections of curated programs
hand-picked by their experts to any
device for viewing anytime anywhere and
if you go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos and use the code microcosmos
to sign up it will only cost you 14.99
for an entire year
the people whose names are on your
screen right now they are our patreon
patrons we are so happy and excited to
be able to continue our search of the
micro cosmos doing weird things like
writing to coral companies and having
them send us samples i think that's just
the beginning of some of the cool stuff
that we can do and these patrons are the
reason that we can do it so thank you so
much to all of them and if you want to
become a patron you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss and why wouldn't you check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there is always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you